[Music]
Sophia v2v it's too hot man
this is Melanie Paul he's an easygoing
lovable fun but forgetful guy that's
where I come in and check him oh that's
me call me now what up baby girl
you where are you I'm not skating
okay well listen don't forget you're
supposed to bring home dinner tonight
for us yeah I'm broken so make sure you
bring home dinner now I won't forget and
do not bring home cups of noodles and
tomatoes again like you did last time do
not do that yeah yeah yeah yeah don't do
that again
yep I'm gonna get the truth all right
see you soon $22 cut out a draftee
Paul's gonna have to stretch that 25
[Music]
hey oh hey Street Tim what's going on Oh
what is it you hear the news
Drake's running for prison that means
instead of a Muslim we're gonna have a
rap and half-and-half tell me that's not
burgers that's not true it's also
offensive half peas and carrots
you know if you believe it you can make
it so that's what I've learned
that's why it's good advice man thanks
so where your hair off do you got any
change for me ah all right nice talking
to you hi man Tim yeah
[Music]
here's a dollar buddy like that Wow
thanks Paul a whole dollar Lily man I'm
a millionaire
you sure are streets in you sure why
would you do that
come back ah never you don't bomb a care
hey man oh hey bro can't get a band-aid
no they come in a box yeah I can't just
give you one they're called band-aids
but bend aid what can you give me one
from like a first aid kit a some time I
know you guys have one back there no we
don't that's a myth
this is my ship and we don't have a
first-aid kit you know uh Jim Jim Jim
what to tell you about that game of
Harry Potter throwing stuff here man no
witchcraft on the ship so fare the
customers man sorry manager Larry this
give me the bad days bro I'll take five
dollars are you serious
[Music]
hey can I get the rotisserie chicken and
kale butternut squash
thank you hey man what happened to the
other guy
oh he's on break so you're stuck with me
that's gonna be 1107 okay hey man this
is gonna sound weird but do you ever
give money to a guy named Tim on the
street yeah I did that's my uncle no way
Street Tim is your uncle you have man as
I live and breathe yeah he kind of lost
it after Nam and he likes living on the
street now so we just kind of let him
you know I go down there and check him
every now and then give him something
make sure he's good wow that's awesome I
love him he's a good guy hey you know
what this one's on me
are you sure I mean you don't have to do
that I trust me dude I got this on
behalf of my own thank you so much you
have no thank you I'm a millionaire
something streets it don't worry about
it man thank you all right yeah
it's a cool guy friends yeah have dinner
okay
so Paul we're no longer friends on
Instagram oh I'm real chill chill chill
just joking just struggling got some
chicken huh wash it down with some
squash fill me some band-aid those are
mine so everything else we can eat them
oh you got a ticket look at that even
got a little handle on what you go you
go you gotta leave I'm a breast man dawg
wait how you know why chicken I'm so
proud of Paul way to step up he didn't
tell us the story of his day until later
but it didn't matter by then because we
were full and happy
[Music]
now the whole tes
you
[Music]